joey the manga man
felix poopy day oh that's me
oh yo
okay uh i was browsing crunchyroll the
other day joey and you know what i
discovered what what that f is wrong
with anime titles
okay
what do you mean
we have here my next life as a
villainness all roots lead to doom well
perfectly understandable title right we
know who the main character is and what
they are planning to do
no we don't
i don't know i don't know how much more
obvious you can get with that okay well
you can apparently so i'm a spider so
what yeah
so what what you you're you're you're
arachnophobic of any kind you don't like
spiders can you explain to me what at
least is happening here uh main
character turns into a spider in an rpg
world and is uh just you know a little
carefree hence the so what although i
will say with this one uh i hate the
fact that they use the word so twice
so i'm a spider so what that's just
awful
it's like grammatically incorrect and
it's just bugging the crap out of me oh
it's bugging the crap out of you sorry
it's spidering the crap out of me my bad
i've been killing slimes for 300 years
and max out my level
damn are they just well spent
are they trying to just explain the
entire plot in the title is that what's
happening yeah so like
so do you want like the serious answer
as to why they call it like this no
well oh yeah maybe maybe let me just go
through them what their reason was sure
let's go let's go through a couple of
ones the hidden dungeon only i can enter
wow exclusivity am i right is there a
reason behind the different color the
dungeon i can hit then only enter
why did it color some of it
is this like is this like hints from
like the zodiac killer he's just like
leaving
in anime titles what the [ __ ] is up with
slime animes the slime diaries how many
slime ones do we need
dude have you ever like touched slime
before yeah
god like
okay okay i get it thanks this feels
good man okay so applying this concept
of naming anime because you know
we're old school anime fans you and i
joey naruto what what would be the
actual name of naruto then i saved the
ninja village and become hukake
[Laughter]
i'm a nine-tailed fox and i'm very sad
because my father left me
that's why that should be cool and my
best friend hates me
what's up with that what's up with that
am i right
they did it wrong that's a much better
title i never finished bleach what would
bleach be because that's also like a
really quick thing don't spoil the whole
thing to be fair i don't know why they
called it bleach i just feel like i
don't know but at least you can't
remember it at least it makes sense i
prefer bleach a thousand times you're
right it doesn't actually maybe believe
it's not a good one
bleach would be something like
i died now i have powers
maybe
that's better you you nailed it on that
one yeah how about this i died
and i like squishing slime slime i like
squishing it bleach the chronicle
bleach and then in brackets bleach
wait i want to think of more i don't
know why this is so funny to me uh
like what what are some of the original
classic anime uh um one piece one piece
what about one piece oh one piece i
never actually finished it either i'm a
really stretchy slime guy type of guy
so what slime i mean she likes like
i am stretchy like slime but i'm
actually rubber
what's up with that
i like homemade
dude they should make more anime titles
that'll like end in like an existential
question like
yeah like like i'm made of slime or am i
who knows what i am really
what is a pirate does anyone know who
they are no wait okay wait one more one
more okay um what did i watch santa moon
uh okay pokemon pokemon is good pokemon
there's a bunch of stupid animals
everywhere let's make them fight
that's awesome i captured animals for my
own self-satisfaction because they enjoy
my company
[Laughter]
it always has to end existential like
with a question
it leaves you read that title and you're
like oh i wonder what i wonder what that
could mean i gotta check it out so funny
i love this
okay explain explain to me why are they
doing these family titles okay so
most if not i think all of these are
originally based off light novels and
there's a trend in the light novel world
where
instead of writing you know how most
books have a blurb at the back to like
tell you what the book is about yeah
yeah well in japan they realized that
younger people just weren't reading
blurbs and were basically just picking
up titles because they thought it was
interesting so i guess um it makes sense
they literally were like what if
the blub is the title
that makes sense i actually makes
perfect sense that's so dumb but yeah
yeah it makes it so dumb but it works
right yeah because you remember you
remember my next villain life is a
villain as all routes lead to doom as
like a really dumb title but you know
exactly what the show is about without
having to read the blog
but it does kind of take away from that
connection with like like oh yeah
pokemon you know exactly what that is
and what that means like yeah yeah i
mean there's there's some like good
titles out there like even today it's
just you know for some reason a lot of
the ones that get turned into anime are
ones with ridiculous titles like this
and they just kept the title yeah and
they were like we could make it like
really catchy and fun and cool but not
this if this is what if this is what the
person who made it says it is i guess
this is what it is have you seen any of
these like this one for example have you
seen this uh no
what about what happens
i've seen the spider one i've seen a
slight one i would be a better name what
would be a better name i don't know uh
[ __ ] spider diaries
spider diaries
yeah that's like vampire diaries because
then i'll be like how can the spider
even write a diary that makes sense
exactly because it's because you're
following the life of the spider right
so it's like spider diaries or like
spider stories or something i don't know
spider story sounds like a really like
nickelodeon movie maybe not spider story
spider spider diaries spider dies
because i hate them all spiders
exterminate them
all spiders must die the old spiders i
like that all right this is just the
start of the video and you explaining it
to me because like that what i really
wanted to do is to see what are some
really bad titles like what are the
worst titles these are just some bad
ones right so i have collected julie the
worst titles of anime of all time
okay bad bet better are you ready to
rate them are you ready to find which
one is actually the worst one you came
to the right place felix because if
anyone is qualified for this video eight
it is watashi
okay so starting off with the legend of
the legend
japanese title
[Laughter]
the legend of the legendary heroes
yep the legendary of the legend of the
legendary heroes have you seen this have
you read this have you watched it i have
i have seen this actually this one this
one is a classic but actually yeah it
actually has decent review
it was made in like what 2011 20 oh yeah
2010 there you go the legend of the
legendary heroes that's like the most
redundant title you could possibly make
no it's not redundant dude it's like
it's like double the effect
you know what i mean it's like it's it's
like they're legendary but like on top
of that legendary status they're even
more legendary it's like it's like it's
like saying like the epic tale of the
epic gamers you know it's like
it sounds like the worst like mobile
phone game or something like [ __ ] okay
the legend of the legendary yeah sure
i'll download that this video is
sponsored by the epic legend of the epic
gamers yes
that's exactly it
okay so i watch this clip and i'm like
what the [ __ ] is happening before the
arrows touch me a clever ruse but if you
could oh god i've never heard of the dog
not if i didn't feel keen on rousing the
fury of your laptop oh man this is
taking me back actually yeah
it's kind of nostalgic
don't tell me reiner loot is an alpha
stigma
what the [ __ ] is happening
he's an alpha sigma alpha sigma sigma
that's so cool
he's not only a legendary hero but he's
an alpha sigma
he's a legendary of a hero at legend
alpha
should we do entirely some of this now i
think about it hey you know what let's
just rate them wait at what out of like
a scale of one to ten yeah so i'm i'm
gonna completely separate the actual
like quality of the show with the title
i'm purely rating it on the yeah
all right you don't have to worry about
pissing off the fanboys come on no one's
a fan of the legend of the legendary
heroes
speak and if they are shame on you
okay to be fair now that i look at it um
it's a pretty wack title not gonna lie
yeah
just the title the legendary hero just
the title
but i don't know man like it came out
off like
like like the epic energy you feel me
no no i don't
there's something like really epic about
the legend of the legend there here is
like holy [ __ ] can you get even more
legendary than that
no you can't you're right you make a
great point thank you
what is the rating i'll rate it three
because it's [ __ ]
okay oh you know what we'll we'll put
this as the benchmark i think i'll rate
this a five out of ten okay i put three
you put five yeah okay we're gonna
average these out later and we'll see
which one is actually the worst okay
moving on what attack
do you do i dare to read this in
japanese dengeki
which one is butt attack out of all
these words
uh
oshioki
how the hell did they become these
because english anime titles are [ __ ]
whack dude why okay to be fair i've
never heard of this show before you've
never heard of butt attack monster girl
guatta guaraman what a man
i think it's got a man nah guar man
oh [ __ ] buddha is in this one that's
awesome oh
my man buddha what's up
so this was made in 1994 jesus i was
born that year
what the this is this is the golden ones
we missed out on the generation above us
okay so this looks like this this is a
one-episode ova which means it was part
of like that really oh i didn't notice
that you're right
yeah in the 90s there was like a massive
like ova boom oh there were so many like
one-shot ovas in the 90s and so many of
them sucked ass and i'm sure
from the look of it looks like this is
one of them so this is a 45 minute ova
okay interesting well let's have a
little clip or a clip of rooney and look
here already i'm excited you're about to
see with i think some of the greatest
anime of your life
let's find out
no that's darth vader
tan
i knew you liked this
[Music]
dark later
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my god i need to [ __ ] watch this
dude honestly
dude wait wait wait wait wait wait
has delivered are you ready for this
let's see
[Music]
[Laughter]
that scroll that's the origin hell yeah
dude
[Applause]
honestly yeah i'm [ __ ] for that oh my
god i have to watch this
that's [ __ ] amazing nice
okay whatever so butt attack punisher
girl gortaman i mean look now that we've
seen the clip of it yeah i mean it's
gonna be hard not to be influenced yeah
exactly
right yeah like you know exactly what
the show is about there's a there's a
girl called gautaman and she punishes
and attacks with her ass you can't argue
with it
you can't argue with that like that
arguably exactly what that's about
actually kind of want to watch it i give
it a 10.
you're gonna give it you know what i'll
i'll give it a strong nine strong nine
all right yeah i'll give it a strong
nine because it's to the point it's
memorable right mm-hmm
and you know exactly what's gonna happen
in it yeah how can you not remember butt
attack punisher girl god oh man how can
you not you're right
exactly all right
next i'm i'm i'm dead i was gonna make a
[ __ ] video on that hell yeah i'm glad
i could find one that you haven't
found the source of that's awesome i my
me
strawberry eggs
okay so so i've heard of this one but
i've never seen it okay
yeah that's a that's a really [ __ ]
weird title the thing about it i thought
that was like a dumb
english translation and they don't know
how to use like maybe like watashi or
something like becomes
me but it literally says i my
me me
yeah
yeah exactly i'm like what the [ __ ] why
do they name it these what does that
mean
i mean strawberries have to come from
somewhere from
oh the eggs okay yeah yeah oh god i
don't know
have you ever seen a strawberry being
born
yeah i do actually they've grown all the
time yes yeah from eggs
they sprout from eggs
no they don't yeah i just hate this
title so much i my knee
that's a very weird title we have a clip
see what it's all about
holy [ __ ] all 13 episodes
oh wow i picked the best quality i could
possibly find jesus christ this is a
very popular anime joey and uh everyone
just
it's all right you want to get clemson
claim from this we forgot about all of
the wonderful times we shared with you
it doesn't matter if you're a man or a
woman
there we go
nice nice list
all i got out of that is the i love
early like 2000's anime like mouth flaps
it's like it's literally just like three
frames of just like open half closed
they try their best
yeah so touching at the end
so touching at the end last part was so
emotional i kind of want to watch it now
what is this the last part i was so
emotional all right
i my me strawberry eggs i might yeah
that's that's a pretty [ __ ] title i'm
i'm gonna i'm gonna have to give that
like a two
damn
okay i get
i can find pisses me out in a good way
wait you prefer that over the legend of
the legendary heroes yeah legend there
yeah
what
okay the next one joey i hate it so much
i hate this one title i hate this i've
seen this one oh my god i hate this
thing though
do you want to read this
yeah
very easy i know that title off by heart
bro do you really
yeah i do oh my god how is that possible
it's an impossible title it's i've never
seen a title of anything that long
do you love your mom and her two-hit
multi-targeted tanks no well do you no
dude this is a great title it's asking a
[ __ ] question to the viewer do you
like it
no i know
existentialism at its finest that seems
to be the pattern here isn't it you
decide you decide is it do you love it
wait so there's alternative titles do
you like your
mom this just ended there
do you like your mom her normal attack
is two attacks at full power okasan
online
that's a such a [ __ ] title
i thought the normal english title was
like kind of all right but that like
that alternative title is crap i i like
the alternative titles so i actually
know that this is a a novel as well so
it kind of ties in with what you said
yeah
and have you read it
yeah yes i have actually really why i've
read it why why'd you like i i did it i
did a video where i rented a japanese
mum for 24 hours oh i saw that yeah yeah
and that was sponsored by this
oh
yeah
i love this title but the anime was
garbage
oh okay yeah they didn't get it didn't
get good reviews i heard that no no what
was bad about it look i love my mom but
i i don't want to see like another
person's mom in like weird
sexualized situations like this
i'm just not into that personally all
right whatever
it's very strange
well you know if you're into that [ __ ]
then go hand your family i don't
understand i don't understand anyone has
like a mom thing that's pretty good no
definitely not a certain swedish guy
well now it seems like i like this i
haven't watched that
all right anyway mom anime three
three yeah
i i kind of like this title so i'll give
it like a six
oh
okay
there moving on to
what the [ __ ] is this you're like i've
watched this one too really what yeah
what the [ __ ] it's it yeah oh here we go
completely fine title story in which i
was kidnapped by
a young lady school to be a sample of
common people
what and you watched this you decided
you know what that one yeah
that one out of thousands i'm watching
that one yep or reading that one yeah
cool that's great it's my life yeah
how was it
uh
i've already forgotten the title story
in which i was kidnapped by a young
lady's school a young lady school how
are you kind of a young lady school yeah
he was kidnapped by young lady school to
be a sample of the peasants i don't get
it i don't understand
so so the plot is basically there is
like a prestigious like high school full
of like
pretty much like rich family like
princesses who live like a princess type
life in order to like fully understand
the common people aka the peasants they
kidnap
a peasant boy to learn the peasant ways
oh
yeah peasant boy casual that's a casual
modern day in slavery
and yo you were like yeah even and i was
like
and i was like hell yeah dog
it is interesting when they're using
like i don't know if this heart is
supposed to be there but i know in like
euro camp they insist on having like the
camp logo there yeah the triangle yeah
isn't that kind of weird yeah i kind of
like it that'll be it's cute this title
whatever zera i don't know i hate it
there
okay i'll i will give this a three
i would have given it more points if
instead of common people they just you
know have the balls to just say peasants
okay
three it is three it is oh my god i uh
this is really annoying
i'm not even joking my mental choices
are completely interfering with my
school romantic comedy that is exactly
what you said that's the thing you read
at the back yeah oh my god that's the
thing japan has like met the game so
hard that they've turned a blurb into a
title
to be fair i i have seen this one oh my
god you've seen them all joey i'm the
anime man felix of course i've seen it
yeah but yet
we're watching
come on
come on no okay okay to be fair to be
fair this is like a ridiculous title but
this anime is actually [ __ ] hilarious
really it's actually really really funny
okay yeah but uh
comedy
my mental multiple choice power is
completely ruining my school romantic
comedy okay
right i mean it's funny i mean the the
title you know they could have gone for
a you know admittedly a little more of a
snappier title but uh i guess they were
just like you know what [ __ ] it we need
to explain this ridiculous plot from the
get-go you know what they should do they
should just name the
like meta tags should be the title
now with the online world right well
actually it's funny because like a lot
of these like longer titles they
actually shorten it to make it a little
more like easier to say oh really yeah
so in the case with this one the the
colloquial title for when referring to
it is
so they take the nor in nornai and they
take the kome in comedy so they all
right so they do uh they try a little
bit i appreciate that that will
definitely they should just name it
light novel comedy roman school 24
episodes uh for three main characters
yeah enjoy the reason there isn't a
million of those already and then would
you like to watch question mark gotta
have a question at the end
that's a bad point though
what if what if there was a show that
was just like so self-aware of how [ __ ]
it is that the title is like are you
sure you want to watch this
are you positive you want to waste your
time to watch this show
oh my god someone has to write that that
is great are you sure about this one bro
it's like a challenge that's great all
right what would you rate this i rate it
three i'll give it a five okay yeah
because it's long but it i mean i
remember it off the top of my head
because it's a good show and it's like
and it's shortened you can shorten it so
you know what i'll give them points for
that effort at least next one doesn't
piss me off i'm actually kind of kind of
want to watch it it's
oh dude
bob
bubba
i'm not sure how you say it it's how
would you say it
oh i like that that kind of flows too
this is like
this is dead ass one of my favorite
manga ever like really
yeah it's like i grew up with this this
[ __ ] is so
insane and like just out there that it's
just so funny yeah because i i i never
heard about it i just googled dumb
titles but then i watched some clips and
i'm like this is just this looks like
standing by right guys
okay maybe not the dub i don't know but
the dom's actually not too bad yeah how
do you say
the yellow afro guy yeah and his power
is that he can control his nose hairs to
attack people
of course
and of course yeah so that's like those
black things coming out of his nose i
can control my nostril hair to attack
people what should i do that's a better
thing what should i do it's at a better
time
and like he has a brother called baby
baby baby
legs
hairs
oh
yeah nice yeah okay i might actually
check this one out what would you rate
it
i mean it's so [ __ ] catchy and so
memorable like that's a 10. yeah i think
it's a 10 too yeah i like it it's
amazing okay we only have a couple more
next up oh my god i don't know why it
pisses me off so much
can you read the japanese
you've seen them all joey
what the [ __ ]
i like immediately recognize the
title the list
i'm like oh this one right well they
don't have bad rating though yeah this
one's actually pretty good give us your
beautiful japanese title
are you busy i know this means what is i
can read it will you save us okay world
end
what do you do at the world end no what
do you do at the end of the world are
you this is the questions again
stop asking me
have you ever seen a title that has not
one not two but three questions
i'm like i'm not ready for this [ __ ]
this is too much man god this is like a
political press event where they just
like keep asking you questions but it's
also a heavy moral question i'm like all
right enter the world are you going to
be busy or what
you're going to be like this like this
this title could just be like
you could just replace it with
brock
end of the world breath
the world's ending bro
i was like world end well then one word
well then yeah
well then which is weird because like i
don't know why i guess like walden is
like the the alternative title to it
because like it's not in the actual like
japanese title it says synonyms
what does that mean
well
again is like the it's like the
abbreviated version uh
because each one of the questions in
japanese ends with sk
weird i don't know i don't know how they
come up with these acronyms it's kind of
funny that's pretty clever i'll give my
mind an extra point for that all right
rating it
rating it i mean look it was a good show
but that title is absolutely ridiculous
so i'll give it like a i'll give it like
a four i'll give it one
i don't know why they couldn't just call
it walden nah
this is way better
another question another moral dilemma
joey is it wrong to pick up girls in a
dungeon is it wrong
is it wrong i'll never tell have you
you've seen this don't tell me you
haven't seen this joey i know you've
watched it
i i have i have the number of the author
on my phone
i've i've gone to dinner when you call
him this can you ask them what the [ __ ]
yeah i mean i said like i asked him like
how did you come up with the title and
yeah i don't know
dude this is super popular what the [ __ ]
yeah this is this this is a really big
show actually huh well i can see why
have you not seen have you not seen
hestia the mean girl hestia the main
girl there in like the the white dress
she she was like everywhere when this
first came out really i wonder why she's
really cute yeah yeah it's got qualities
yeah
she's got a great personality
i kind of want to see her now sorry
[Music]
oh this is the opening
all right i see is it wrong gentlemen
all right what would you rate it i mean
i like this title because you know again
it's memorable i'm not just saying that
because i'm friends with the author i
genuinely do like this title so i'm
gonna give like an eight oh okay i'll
give it five all right fair enough fair
enough
the king
of all this is where it all started dude
really yeah i i would say this is where
it all started i'm glad we finished up
with it then yeah yeah
i feel if this show didn't get as
popular as it did we wouldn't really
like insane
holy [ __ ]
my little sister can't be this cute i
love the the incest that's great just
right there and the title
yeah right like just no holds bad like
yes i think my sister what of it that's
what that's what the title should have
been i [ __ ] my sister one of it
joey i need to be monetized
i i hug my sister sideways
that's okay right
what of it
yeah what of it have you seen this uh
yeah unfortunately
it's not good is it not i mean there's
lots of like hardcore fans of this show
but i i never thought it was good why
was it so popular
incest is popular i guess
[Music]
more than bug girl
yeah i know it's a true crime is this
the one
[Music]
it's kind of not cute at all actually
right
my little sister can't be this annoying
should have been the yeah
yeah who's getting punched i saw someone
getting punched i like this and they're
both getting fired
this show is literally if like 30 day
fiance wasn't anime
okay like it's it's like that level of
trash i like that that actually makes me
want to watch
damn love third and apn all right what
would you rate this type this has to be
a really low then or three i guess i
mean look here's the thing as like as as
much as the show kind of sucks it did
kind of like birth or like set a
foundation of like which is why anime
titles actually why it should be burned
to hell we should have destroyed a
uh you know what i'll give this a six
okay all right let's see uh let me do
quick math and the winner is
i think it's beer before right because
we gave that a 10. well okay the best
title out of all these is
[Music]
that's it
yes
but that the worst one
is story in which i was kidnapped by a
young lady school to be the sample of
the car that is the worst one that is
absolutely the worst one i'm sorry
that's absolutely the worst that is the
worst anime title we found at joey thank
you for helping me out with these i i
could probably find you one worse no
stop it i don't want to know it i have
one in mind actually okay okay all right
a challenger appears i don't know if i
want it worth it i don't know if this
some some stuff is better to leave dark
and crumbled
up in the darkness now after after you
see this one no i'm gonna feel sick oh
god oh god
oh my god
oh
oh god it's so long i am a high school
boy
and a successful light novel author but
i'm being struck
i'm being strangled by a female
classmate who is a voice actress and is
younger than me
jesus christ
why
when i saw this for the first time i was
like no [ __ ] way
is this a real title
how do you know like reading looking at
this uh cover like how do you know what
is what time to play i would think time
to play was the name of this
yeah right time to play is the the name
of the first volume because of course
they had to separately name the volumes
as well what the [ __ ] jesus christ i
just imagine big coming up with this
title while this is happening like oh
[ __ ]
i'm being straight like we have to put
as much information about the story into
the title as possible as bad as it is i
i still firmly believe that this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yeah is the worst
and i i stand by it joey yeah fair
enough fair enough i thank you for
helping me rate the worst anime titles
of all time of course of course anytime
check out joey's channel link is in the
description you talk about what does he
talk about again i forgot i don't know
some kind of japanese cartoon i guess
check them out i talk i talk exclusively
about xiaomi sample if you like to see
50 videos on the showing sample come to
your boy
i don't think that's gonna work well
good luck with that man i'm sure that
would be great
all right thanks for joining have a
great one and epic profess yeah
yeah
you thought it was gay
but true relevance never really died
welcome to the first undead game use any
item in your inventory and make memes
inside tuber simulator add some of our
patented stickers in there stickers are
emotions memes our emotions express your
emotions with me
show them for likes share them for love
get up for free
and who knows
maybe i'll review your memes the
greatest honor of all time
circle baby download it make a meme
[Music]
we need subtitles on this